[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants rouges trop haut
à quel jeu avez vous joué aujourd'hui
je parie que vous avez fait de la
peinture pas trop haut je vais finir la
donne se porterait pas preneur soit
rachat d'or je compte sur toi nounours
bon les seuls gros pow pow wow qui voit
là j'suis sûr qui verra pas que son
tableau est à l'envers
bonsoir bugeaud petit entraînement cieux
grands artistes au travail
ne perdons pas de temps
je réponds à popeye la fict avait
vraiment un drôle de talent et ma main
elle a dit heureusement que ma fille ait
la passe et est là ne perdons pas de
temps
mes pinceaux tu as raison
ne perdons pas de temps ils ont retenu
malheureux avec vous tout est noir ou
fait de la peinture beaumont que cette
amusante un rouge et lula dont claude au
batofar gauche on mouille au lit on ce
coupon hollow vous êtes trop vilain
c'est pas possible vos le choc c'est
formidable aventure oui on aura pas
[Musique]
d'accord qui marche on shoppe vous
coucher
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
nos deux petits amis sont bien turbulent
ce soir au trot le fauche c'est faux
avec mes amis
le son mon pauvre nounours nicolas et
pimprenelle ont été très méchant avec
toi ô mon pauvre tableau à taureaux une
oeuvre par m j'aurais pu l'offrir à
lannepax tionale galerie ne pleure pas
new york ce qui en fera d'autres c'est
vrai j'en ferai d'autres gilleron dra le
marché mais je ne ferai plus le portrait
de pimprenelle
je ferai le vôtre a trop
fait froid votre preuve allons grand
peintre
il est très tard en août
bonne nuit les enfants
allez vite vous coucher et soyez plus
sage que nicolas et pimprenelle et fêtes
de bourg
[Musique]
oh